الفساد عارض او طارئ لا يمكن ان يكون نظام
على الاطلاق نهائي هو ما يسميه احنا يعني
نظريا فوضى وبالتالي هو عاده ياتي في
فترات الفجوات العصريه او فتى فترات
الفراغ ياتي يعني ولا شك طبعا يعبر عن
ايضا مفهوم حتى المؤامره ايضا هناك يعني
لا يمنع انه ممكن يكون هو ايضا يستخدم
للمؤامره لكنه هو طارئ لا يمكن ان يكون
نظام ولا يمكن ان يكون اعتياد
اليوم مستوى الدائقه الفنيه في في العالم
العربي في الخليج في السعوديه يعني تختلف
المساله
نعم ما في شك
الاساليب الفنيه الاساليب الادبيه
التيارات بشكل عام المبدعين عددهم تمركزهم
الوسائل التي تخدمهم وسائل عرضهم هذه كلها
طبعا تشكل ذائقه مجتمع في فتره معينه في
مرحله معينه عبر وسائل ايضا معينه ما في
شك طبعا
وممكن ايضا هذه تجني على المجتمع يعني اذا
عودناهم على
الجمال الدائم او على الاقل لذا كثر او
بالغنا فيه يتحول الى عبء عبء جمالي يعني
فيصير في مشكله ايضا في تقبل اي حركه
جديده فيما بعد يعني يصير في صعوبه في
تقبل حتى المختلف المختلف حتى بالزمن او
بالجيل يصير في ايضا حتى صعوبه في تقديم
النفس يعني المبدع الجديد كيف يقدم نفسه
المبدعه الجديده كيف تقدم نفسها يعني ممكن
يكون عبء عاده التوازن بالامور هذه تاخذ
فتره بعد ما تنتهي
حاله الضجيج او حاله المعاصره ترشح الامور
فتتضح الرؤيه